and welcome to today's live broadcasts
rare inherited mutations in autism
spectrum disorder presented by Maria
Shara
she is an assistant professor at the
University of Texas Southwestern Medical
Center I am Marjorie torres of labyrinth
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
reads labyrinth is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask the question box located on
the far left of your screen and type
your questions into the drop down box
that appears on the screen will answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
board at the bottom or center of your
screen or use the ask a question box to
let us know that you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the accreditation button
located in the promotional board at the
bottom or center of your screen and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Maria Shore I will now turn the
presentation over to her thank you and
hello everyone thanks for joining in
today and I'd like to tell you a little
bit about genetics and autism spectrum
disorders so I'll cover a little bit of
introduction on that and then tell you
about some of the things that we're
doing in the lab to address genetic
questions in autism autism is a
neurodevelopmental disorder that's
characterized by impaired communication
skills social behavior of normalities
and instead of restricted and repetitive
behaviors the latest prevalence data
from the CDC suggests that autism is
prevalent in approximately 1% of
children and then this statistic depends
on whether you're considering strict
autism spectrum disorder or
the more syndromic forms and the latest
data on the affected male to female
ratio comes from a study by looms and
colleagues from the University College
of London and suggesting that this ratio
of affected males to females is closer
to say 2-1 the economic burden that
autism spectrum disorder causes on
society is about 175 billion dollars a
year for the United States and just to
put this in perspective that's larger
than the sum of the economic costs of
cancer stroke and heart disease all
combined the genetics of autism is
pretty complex and heterogeneous and
even though autism is one of the most
highly heritable on your psychiatric
conditions it's been really challenging
to identify specific causative genes and
traditionally genes have been identified
on the basis of overlap with
well-documented monogenic syndromes
accounting for about 3% of cases and
this includes fragile X syndrome red
syndrome
tuberous sclerosis and Angelman just to
name a few and then 5% of cases are due
to chromosomal abnormalities or copy
number variants or what we call or
referred to as C and B and these arise
de novo meaning that they're not
inherited from parents and arise
spontaneously in the gametes of parents
and examples of these include regions on
chromosome 16 p1 1.2 or chromosome 15 Q
1 1 2 1 3 and those accounts for about
5% of cases and from in more recent
years a large scale whole exome
sequencing studies indicated that up to
15% of cases are due to de novo point
mutations and examples of these genes
include at the end - ACH t8 and others
and we know from several studies in the
field that recesses point mutations
accounts for up to 3% of cases and this
number is a little bit underestimated
because the number refers to complete
loss of function point mutations and it
doesn't take into account for example
missense mutations or changes
amino-acids and just you know we still
don't know for the vast majority of
cases what the underlying genetic causes
are and just to give you an idea about
the heterogeneity of autism spectrum
disorder and the complex genetics this
is just showing some of the copy number
variants that have been implicated in
autism and you can see just from you
know quick look at this circus plot that
deletions and duplications of the same
region can give rise to a multitude of
neurobehavioral neurodevelopmental and
other phenotypes affecting pretty much
all organ systems so anywhere from
autism spectrum disorder to intellectual
disability developmental delay language
impairment or learning disability all
the way to cardiac abnormalities and
skeletal abnormalities and a host of
other phenotypes and the thing is true
for single nucleotide variants where you
have several mutations in several genes
give rise to either syndromic forms of
autism or non syndromic forms and
mutations in this gene can be both de
novo meaning not inherited from the
parents or inherited or in some cases
both de novo as well as inherited
mutations from the same genes and I'm
only showing the top 90-something genes
that have very strong confidence to be
associated with autism and this comes
from a scale that based on the Simon
Foundation gene scoring module and even
though up to 800 genes have been
implicated in autism we really have very
strong evidence for only a few hundred
and this perhaps demonstrates better the
genetic contribution of these types of
mutations and in the different genes to
the overall autism spectrum disorder
population so there is no single gene
that can encounter up to 2% of cases of
autism and it's a collection of genes
and mutations that have individually
very small effect on the overall
population of patients so from all of
these genetic studies of
as probably decade or so we know that
autism is more a collection of rare
disorders mutations and individual genes
that cannot account for for all of the
heritability on their own or
individually I should say so this really
complicates how we think about
therapeutic strategies for autism and
this in panel a where you have a found
genetic mutation and a patient
population you take it to preclinical
models for example a mouse model and
then you develop therapeutics and test
them back in the models and the patient
population it's really a very simplistic
pathway that I don't think it's
definitely not that little -
neurodevelopmental disorders but I don't
actually think it's applicable to most
human disorders and so the way we think
about autism now after everything we
know about the genetics underlying the
disease that it's going to be we're
going to have to think about pathways to
group patients together whether it's by
genes by molecular defect or a circuit
deficit or an endo phenotype and then
start to individualize therapies based
on these different underlying genes or
molecular pathways and to really
individualize the way we think about
therapeutics and our approach developing
them um so now I'm going to tell you
about a little bit of what we do in the
lab so we're interested in gene
discovery in autism spectrum disorder
but also in functional characterization
and of these genes that we find and then
to really try to understand the
molecular mechanisms underlying disease
with the hopes that someday we can we
and others can develop biomarkers for
diagnosis as well as targets for
therapeutics and I'm going to start with
a brief intro on the different
approaches of gene discovery in autism
that the field has been taking and then
what we are on doing in the lab as well
so there are several large-scale genomic
studies that are ongoing and a couple of
them I'm just going to talk about the
two biggest ones in autism and that's
the project by Autism Speaks and Google
it's called the missing project and
the plan here is to sequence entire
genomes of 10,000 individuals with
autism and their family members and then
the second initiatives from the
assignments foundation or the safari
spark assignments foundation powering
autism research for knowledge the plan
there is to sequence genomes from close
to 50,000 individuals with autism and
their family members and then there are
two really planned future projects that
include not just autism but for several
conditions one is the UK biobank with a
plan for sequencing 500,000 individuals
and the other one is that all of us
that's either the NIH and the plan there
is the sequence 1 million individuals
and for these 2 large datasets there
will be genetic as well as phenotypic
and other kinds of medical record data
for these patients and then there is a
very I just want to point out the genome
ad database which is a very extremely
useful resource in the field and the
community and this open-source database
contains 15 to 15 thousand 500 whole
genome sequences and 123 thousand whole
exome sequences for a variety of
conditions and this is really helpful
because we can start to get an idea
about the allele frequencies for the
different variants that we identify in
our own disease cohorts to try to figure
out whether these variants are benign or
potentially disease causing or not and
also some genetics is really all about
increasing the signal-to-noise ratio and
since it's such a heterogeneous and
complex disorder both phenotypic ly as
well as genetically and one approach
that we're taking that's definitely you
know it's been attempted by several
groups as well in the field and it's a
straightforward combining information
from phenotype as well as ancestry
information and genomics and I'll come
back to the ancestry part in a little
bit
but the idea to fill up typically
certified patients um you know this
includes having detailed phenotypic
information and detailed clinical
information about the patient population
as well as to look at the sub phenotypes
and the extremes of the spectrum and
then to apply different genomics methods
in combination for example whole genome
sequencing and then information from
genome-wide chip seek data so in order
to be able to annotate non-coding
variants and then also utilize ancestry
stratification which is basically
looking at patient populations with a
common ethnic background and this just
increases our power to map the genes
that the poor in particular the ones
with inherited mutations and then we
we've recently launched a study across
the DFW area and nationwide to recruit
families and patients into cohorts with
common ethnic backgrounds so that we can
do these types of disease gene mapping
and then the idea is that using this
multi-pronged approach we can start to
determine what the contribution of
feature gene is do the overall disease
as well as a contribution to different
genetic models and then to eventually be
able to learn about the genetics of
normal language development and social
behavior and as I said this is ongoing
in the field and our own lab is really
interested in the inherited variants and
in utilizing this ancestry information
to identify them so I just want to give
a brief introduction about whole genome
sequencing and the ideas that we want to
identify noble disease-causing genes and
pathways and the reason we rely on whole
genome sequencing is because it just
gives us a better exome or a better
sequence of the coding portion of the
genome as well so we can look at coding
variants with more confidence and then
we can also look sort to look at
non-coding variants or regulatory
mutations and several studies have
already are already underway to do that
in the community and then it also allows
us to look at copy number variants copy
number information and be able to
determine whether there's copy number
variants at play and then struck
information meaning larger structural
variants in the genome and then it will
allow us to test the various inheritance
models as well and then the second step
is to really be able to validate these
variants we identify to the whole genome
sequencing using an independent
technology such as Sanger sequencing or
more high throughput methods of doing
genotyping and then to do functional
characterization and neuronal cultures
to be able to introduce these mutations
whether there's also function or
missense using the CRISPR cast line
technology and be able to test what the
impact that these variants are on the
protein and then on neurons eventually
and so just to give you a sense of what
whole genome sequencing gives us the
human genome has about 3 billion base
pairs and we want to try to go from that
to a single mutation or a combination of
mutations that are potentially
disease-causing so that's a really big
pool of variants that we have to deal
with and first what we do is we map
these bases by comparing the sequences
that we get to the reference human
genome or what was established by the
National by the NIH has the normal
genome and 99.9 percent of our genomes
are identical the remaining 0.1% I
really would carry sequence differences
that vary between individuals and the
vast majority of those say to four
million variants are at this point one
percent accounts to theta4 ammonium
variants and most of these are really
benign
and then we compare the variants that we
identify and effective individuals to
the same family members who are
unaffected and try to eliminate variants
that are potentially be 9 and then we
initially focus on the 3 percent of the
genome that calls for protein or what we
call the exome just because this is
easier to interpret and then as the
field of non-coding
genomics evolves more and you know we
have will have more robust methods to be
able to assign significance to
non-coding variants as well and then we
can test multiple genetic models through
this so are these variants de novo or
are they inherited from the parents
what's the mode of inheritance and then
we can also look for known autism
causing mutations in genes that have
already been established as
disease-causing and determine whether
those are explai or not so just to
summarize this in a schematic we start
out with the whole genome sequencing we
look for structural variants and copy
number variants then we also look for
single nucleotide mutations or in those
or what we call in those which are
smaller insertions and deletions and the
whole genome sequence also gives us snip
genotypes which are single nucleotide
polymorphisms that are at a high of a
frequency in the population and then for
we use those to basically determine the
runs of homozygous in the genome that
one I'll talk about in a minute but that
allows us to really look for inherited
variants and then in terms of
disease-causing so if you look on the
left side of the schematic the
structural variants CNB's snv's and in
Dells we eliminate variants that have an
allele frequency of greater one than 1%
in public databases and this is because
those are likely to be benign and then
we focus on the ones that have an ugly
frequency of 1% or less and we call
those rare and the severe structural
variants can be even snv's we then
proceed to determine whether they're de
novo or inherited because we have this
information from the pedigree structure
and from the genomic sequence of other
family members and then we come up with
a list of candidate disease-causing
variants that we can annotate in a
multitude of ways so for example we can
do functional annotation where in the
proteins this variant 'full and what is
the impact or the predicted impact on
the protein function and then we can do
regulatory element annotation that I
touched on briefly on a few slides back
which is to help us determine whether it
is non-coding variants fall and any
regulatory
and the genomes are they in promoter
regions enhancer regions or some other
conserved elements that do not code for
protein but that affect the protein
expression level and function and then
we can also do disease annotation
meaning IDs variants associated with any
known human diseases
have they been seen before and then we
narrow down our list
eventually together what is
disease-causing in that particular
family or that particular cord and as I
mentioned my lab is interested in the
inherited variants and so one way to
find the inherited variants that are
recessive the inherited is to do
homozygosity analysis and that has been
traditionally used in consent -
populations where the parents are
related and that's typically as first
cousins which increases the rates for
recessive mutations in the offspring and
then we can find these runs of
homozygous a in the genome and determine
and look for recessive mutations falling
within these regions so offspring from
first cousin marriages 6% of their
genome is homozygous and so we can
narrow down our search to that part of
the genome using this type of an
approach and even though this homozygous
the analysis has been traditionally
developed and used for confinement as
populations we can still apply that to
non consignments populations where we
suspect that there is a founder mutation
due to more distant shared ancestry more
distant relative to for example first
cousin parents or second cousin parents
and so we can use this approach when we
are interested in our recessive
mutations and now I just want to give
one example of a dominantly inherited
mutation that we had identified using
whole exome sequencing and we had a
pedigree of the family where the
affected individuals had intellectual
disability learning delay speech delay
and a set of restricted interests and
autism
like features for example socially
social behavior abnormalities and there
were no additional phenotypes in this
family it was quite a large family and
in this pedigree there are shaded
symbols refers to affected individuals
the unshaded symbols effect refer to
unaffected individuals and I want to
point out one individual here shaded in
gray and that the phenotype was not
exactly matching his very mildly
affected compared to other family
members and then the Square symbols to
pretend males and the circle symbol to
present females so we did whole exome
sequencing in this family where we
sequence
pretty much everyone except for two
individuals in the family and we had a
good coverage of the exome where the
coding sequence of the genome where the
read depth of about eighty C X and an
average coverage of 96% at 10 X so this
is a good quality whole exome sequence
and then the way we did the analysis was
first we looked at the total number of
variants so these are all average number
of variants per exomes this is the
aggregate from all the exons of the
family members and there were around
27,000 total variants and those are all
noble and have not been seen in public
beta papers or I should say this I'm
sorry this is the total number of
pairings and then we narrowed down our
search to nonsynonymous variants and
those are about 10,000 and then we
wanted to focus on the rare ones and
meaning the ones that had a minor of
this frequency of less than 1% in public
databases after that we looked at the
1,000 genomes the NHLBI ESP database and
Complete Genomics 50 to excellence as
well as an internal database at the
Walsh lab that had 831 exomes and so we
filtered out everything that has a minor
of the frequency of greater one than 1%
and we were left with about 600 rare
variants and then
we focus our attention on the
heterozygous variance and the reason for
that up for that was that we were
assuming a dominant mode of inheritance
since the father and that pedigree was
also affected and we were left with
around 500 variants that were
heterozygous and rare and then we never
found our search to variance that was
shared by all the affected children as
well as the affected father that were
not present in the unaffected mothers
and that were really unique to that
family and then we ended up with 16
variants that could potentially be
disease-causing in that pedigree um so
those 16 variants really affected
through a 16 genes so we didn't have
variants in the same gene they affected
16 GS and if we look at the effect of
these variants on the protein all of
them were missense mutations except for
one full non frameshift deletion and
then the rest were also more missed and
we had a stop gain mutation and a stop
loss mutation so two of these variants
really had severe effects to the stop
gain and the stop loss mutations this is
just to summarize so we get to the 16 we
know the to the various have a severe
effect but we really just wanted to take
an unbiased approach and look at all 16
variants so to be able to pinpoint the
disease-causing variants or variant in
this particular family we recruited
additional family members so that we're
not initially included in the whole
exome sequencing and this is the family
of the affected father in addition to
the two children who are indicated in
red and who are not subject to the
initial holdings of sequencing and then
we performed a validation of these
sixteen variants in all of the pedigree
using standard sequencing and then also
segregation analysis whether it's
variance aggregates with the phenotype
and the family structure and we were
able to narrow it down to a single
variant and
I was one one of the two that had the
severe effect which was a slop game in
this GPM d12 so the dominant
gettinghired the PMD 12 mutation that we
found resulted in a stop codon and then
in a 50% decrease in protein levels in
the year 2012 and the affected
individuals and debris and then we were
also able to find an additional unveil
in this gene at the novo mutation that
was not inherited from parents and this
pedigree where the child was affected
with intellectual disability but you
also have very ventricular nodes liver
heterotopia so with what is PSM d12 and
what does it do PSM d-tools
includes a subunit of the regulatory
complex of the proteasome and that's
involved in protein turnover in the cell
where proteins are added to where your
big cousin is added to substrate
proteins through the action of several
enzymes ubiquitin activating enzyme or
e1 and ubiquitin conjugating enzyme or
e2 and a ubiquitin ligase or EC and then
poly ubiquitinated substrates are then
targeted to the proteasome for
degradation so PSM d12
in codes includes a subunit of this
proteasome the 26s proteasome and this
is the subunit it is also known as our
pn v and the mutations fall and this
unit which was a regulatory part of the
lid on the 26 s producer and we know
that casein need 12 is ubiquitously
expressed but with a high expression in
the brain as well and in all and really
all regions of the brain and more
recently there was a report with de novo
PSN GB mutations that were identified in
a cohort with intellectual disability so
this independently demonstrated that in
our mutation really causes intellectual
disability and you see in that
particular pedigree and then our
analysis really showed that there can be
inherited mutations in GM d 12 as well
then we also you know detected that
mutation and a patient with an
intellectual disability and
periventricular no Judaizers opiate so
potentially it can also cause brain
structural defects but we don't know
that for sure we have to review more MRI
studies in these patients um now I'm
going to tell you about a little story
on how we're trying to look at the
molecular mechanisms once we actually
identify a gene and through different
genomics approaches so we had found a UV
3p missense mutation and family with
autism and then several groups
independently found complete loss of
function mutations in the same gene that
were associated with intellectual
disability that syndrome the patients
have severe ID developmental delay they
like completely like speech and they
have microcephaly or smaller brain and
hypotonia or low muscle tone and feeding
difficulties in addition to a set of
distinct facial dismorphism then this
was called Kaufman ocular cerebral
facial syndrome so we know that the
missense mutations
meteo understands mutation was
identified in a family with autism and
then there was several complete loss of
function mutations that were identified
in the severe intellectual disability
syndrome and this is just to show that
all of these early complete loss of
function mutations and then this is
where the autism mutation that we had
found was in the heck domain this is the
catalytically active domain of this new
Akutan ligase and we knew that this
residue was highly conserved and an in
silico prediction suggested that it
potentially affects folding of this
hecht our catalytic domain of the
protein but we really didn't know what
the missense mutation was doing so at
the time it was called a candidate we
called it a candidate mutation for the
for autism in that family but we had
seen a lot of these examples where if
you completely inactivate the protein
you have severe neurological phenotypes
and even sometimes perinatal lethality
but when you partially inactivate them
you have autism spectrum
order typically on the more severe end
of the spectrum as well with ASD
negative to epilepsy or seizures and UV
to me is also a member of the proteasome
pathway it's an e3 ubiquitin ligase that
conjugates ubiquitin to who substrate
proteins and several members of this
pathway are you take it in your
developmental disorders I told you a
little bit about psmt 12 how we and
others have identified the temptation
and intellectual disability
there's also mutations in for example
unity - a which is an e to I between
conjugating enzyme that are associated
syndromic intellectual disability and
also Havel one which is another eg
because in my case but probably the most
well-known of this family of proteins is
yuugi 3a which is the gene underlying
Angelman syndrome so you B 3 B is in
that same family of proteins
it is also ubiquitously expressed and
then this just shows this is just text
data for expression and human tissue and
it's really expressed everywhere across
tissues but the red arrows show that
it's expressed in different regions of
the brain and to similar levels under
really the highest expression assembly
tested so at the time nothing else was
known about TVs maybe other than it's an
issue of Akutan ligase and so we did
some preliminary experiments and we
found that by in situ hybridization that
ubzb is expressed in human cortex and
that it's expression is modulated by
depolarization in primary neurons so we
had done we had cultured primary human
neurons and depolarize them and found
that it's expression drops by about 50%
and then when we transfer primary mouth
I poked ample neurons with construct
carrying the BTB ast mutation that we
had some sense mutations that we had
found we found that it results and
dramatic decrease in dendritic
complexity in the neurons just showing
an example of a such here on
and then this is the quantification
visual analysis where the mutant is
indicated in red compared to wild-type
or most-respected so this is really
interesting to us because several autism
genes are crucial components of activity
dependent signaling networks at synapses
and I know this is a busy slide but
basically this is a schematic of the
synapse from a wonderful review and
pretty much all of the players that the
synapse that have some sort of activity
dependent signaling function have been
identified in patients with with several
neurodevelopmental disorders including
autism so we were really excited about
that and then you know we obviously
wanted to determine what the role of EBP
was in the brain because those in vitro
experiments and primary cultures were
more gain-of-function overexpression
experiments so in order to do that we
made the constitutively based QB
knockout mouse model as well as the
conditional avail of PvP me so that we
can delete it in specific regions of the
brain and in the brain and then in
specific regions of the brain and right
now we're characterizing the effect of
EBT be lost the function on your own or
differentiation and function and we're
also doing a comprehensive behavioral
analysis to determine if you've ECB has
any function in mediating cognition
social behavior communication and other
behaviors in autism spectrum disorder or
just white behaviors and then what we're
really interested in is to determine
what the substrates of PVC B are for
that were doing global proteomics
experiments to try to determine what you
base maybe is ubiquitinated and what's
essentially mediating the phenotypes
when you're a developmental phenotypes
when ubtv is disrupted so just you know
we confirmed that we can knock out to be
TB this is a consistent of knockout
qpcr from the cortex showing that that
money is gone and this is a Western blot
showing that the protein is gone and
right now we have the
allele and we're deleting it
specifically in the brain first with an
S decree meeting and then the consensus
of line really allowed us to be able to
look at you base to be expression
pattern in the brain in more detail so
this is the heterozygous that has like
the answers than the locus and then this
is the wild-type control that there's no
staining and we found that it's really
expressed to very moderate levels
everywhere in the brain but you know
it's highly expressed in the hippocampus
as well as cortical layers v 2 and 3 and
then the retro Spaniel area of the
cortex and other regions as well so it's
really a lot of to do a comprehensive
check on its expression pattern in the
brain and then we also know that you
know the human patients that have you
basically a loss of function are in the
third percentile for body weight and
they have microcephaly or smaller brain
and then they're also shorter and thighs
and so we check them out my study made
for by the way that we saw that there is
this decrease in body weight as well
approximately 30 percent decrease in
body weight upon loss of heebie-jeebie
and then an approximately 10 percent
decrease in length as well and then we
looked at the brain size in these mice
and we found that there that was also
decreased and this is about 25 percent
decrease but you know when you plot the
brain to body weight ratio there's no
difference so because we know that these
mice are overall smaller and size and
just to compare as a print organ we
check the best case and we also saw a
25% decrease in the way to the test so
The MITRE overall smaller and with
smaller organs
sizes and weight and really modeling the
way Taino type in the human patients
and as I said really interested in
identifying the substrates that modulate
the phenotype in the CBD be upon you if
you need disruption and to do that we're
performing proteomics experiments where
we're looking at whole proteome when
what you know when you knock how to miss
you you order the proteins better
whether the proteins that are stabilized
and then what are the proteins that are
degraded in the wild-type condition and
we're also looking at to see what
applies are being ubiquitinated in the
wild conditions that are no longer
ubiquitinated when you lose you eat so
and then looking at the intersection of
these two lists specifically to find the
substrates so I started out my talk
telling you about the complex and
heterogeneous genetics of autism and how
we're starting to look at it as a
collection of rare disorders and
hopefully with more with all of this
data from all of these large scale
sequencing studies throughout once that
comes then we'll be able to start
teasing apart what these specific
disorders are and how can we group
patients by genetic specific genetic
defects a specific pathway defects and
by pathway I don't you know necessarily
mean for example chromatin remodeling or
synaptic genes but really more specific
pathways that that can be targeted with
therapeutics and I hope that I was able
to give you an overview of different
genetics and what you're doing in the
lab and how we're trying to tackle this
and I'd like to thank my lab members my
collaborators at UT Southwestern and
outside Chris Walsh Wade Harper my
greenberg and then really the patients
and their family members for
participating in a lot of studies and
for really making this possible I'm
being partners in this journey and our
collaborators for sequencing and
proteomics at the Broad Institute and
for generation of the mouse models here
at UT Southwestern and our funding
sources thank you
Thank You dr. sugar for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to add please do so
an app just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left of
your presentation window type your
questions into the box that appears on
your screen and click the send button or
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for let's get started
our first question is what are some of
the emerging pathways that are disrupted
in autism um yeah so um from all of
these large scale sequencing studies
over the past you know 6 years or so we
know that chromatin remodeling genes
that encodes for chromatin remodeling
proteins are really uh implicated in
autism and we know that genes that
encode for proteins that function at the
synapse are important and also genes
that are involved in protein homeostasis
for instance protein translation or
regulating protein translation or
regulating protein degradation so we're
really starting to develop our the
different pathways that are underlying
autism and we also you know can when we
overlay data from genomics to
transcriptomic data we're starting to
also figure out what different
developmental stages or different stages
in brain development that are really
important the different areas in the
brain that are really important thank
you for that answer
our next question is what is the overall
contribution of rare inherited variants
to ASD yeah that's a very good question
so I had mentioned in the introduction
that we know that at least 30% of cases
are due to these variants but I think
this is really underestimated because we
have a lot of missense mutations for
example or single base pair changes or
single amino acid changes that we
really don't know how to assess with in
silico computational tools reliably and
so we need you know all of these
functional studies to be able to
determine whether distances are
disease-causing or not and there are
several studies underway where people
are trying to design these
high-throughput functional as they stick
as these variants and determine what the
impact is on protein function I think
it's not really about genome or
inherited variants per se but it's more
about the genes and as I've shown some
examples where you know whether it's de
novo mutations or inherited mutations
and the same genes can give rise to
neurodevelopmental phenotypes but I
think you know looking at trying to take
these multiple approaches of identifying
Deneuve variants as well as inherited
variants just to be able to identify new
genes it's really you know it's going to
be key to to use multiple approaches and
be able to identify all these variants
once again thank dr. Maria sharor for
her presentation I would also like to
thank lab roots for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through june of 2018
you will receive an email from labyrinth
letting you know in this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcements with your colleagues who
might have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon
goodbye